hi this is Matt Damon I'm Julianne Moore
and we're doing a wired auto-complete
interview right I wish you the best
Matt Damon related to Ben Affleck
actually they did some genealogy thing
and we found out that that we have some
relative from the 1600s who was up who
was a bricklayer who is we have in
common a common ancestor related is Matt
Damon in Game of Thrones or even Game of
Thrones I'm into Game of Thrones but I'm
not in Game of Thrones
Matt Damon an environmentalist
co-founded water.org which is a clean
water and sanitation foundation if
caring about the environment and wanting
others to care about the environment
makes you an environmentalist than yes
of course I am it's Matt Damon a flat
earther I'm not yeah
pretty convinced the earth is round
though Kyrie Irving the point guard for
the Boston Celtics who is a flat earther
is very welcome in Boston and we love
him is Matt Damon
singing Scotty doesn't know I'm not was
so there was a movie my friends directed
a movie called Eurotrip and I sang this
song it was very funny it was called
Scottie doesn't know one of my roommates
from college actually wrote the song and
sang it and I lip synced it it's Matt
Damon moving in Nice Ville Florida I'm
not there are stories that come on the
internet various towns I've been told
that I'm moving to about six or seven
different towns small towns in different
states I don't know where that comes
from I think just wishful thinking they
want you to move to their town is Matt
Damon dead I hope not terrible it's not
dead well maybe culturally speech maybe
I'm over he's so dead what is Julianne
Moore hair color Julianne Moore hair
colour red good Julianne Moore real name
what is Julianne Moore real name is
julianne Smith is it really yes it
really is my name is Julie first name
and anomie second name Smith is my last
name but when I joined the Union there
was already at Julianne Smith the Julie
a Smith a J a Smith a you know every
every variation on the name so they said
choose another name honey so I went they
said well my father's middle name
more and my mother's first name was Anne
so I wanted to make sure I didn't hurt
anybody's feelings so I used I slam the
Anne onto the Julie so I can use both
very professionally so my real name is
Julie Smith oh my goodness when that was
a very conscientious choice of the actor
name what is Julianne Moore doing now
I'm sitting with Matt Damon yes and
moving on what is Julianne Moore zodiac
sign I'm a Sagittarius Libra Oh me but
when's your birthday December 3rd oh
that's so great all right what is she
and more eat Julian what is Jude
what does I'm sorry what does that is
correct what does Julian more eat I
don't eat meat and I eat fish what's
your dream meal like what's your
deathbed meal I would have like valayan
soul bread and broiled steamed grilled I
can have butter sauce okay and maybe
some spinach and some truffle fries
Julianne Moore does not like mashed
potatoes and Jamie's favorite things do
there much speaks of herself and most
people wouldn't think about you okay Oh
Matt Damon meet Ben Affleck oh my god
I've heard this a million times he was
eight and I was ten and our mothers
introduced us
how did Matt Damon get into Harvard was
it legitimate
I applied oh yeah I heard Jerrod
Kushner's parents paid like two and a
half million bus oh yeah we didn't have
we didn't roll like that no I actually
had to apply things I still dropped out
how did Matt Damon get famous probably
Good Will Hunting was were the one that
really people got to know us for Ben and
I both done a lot of movies before then
but none that it really kind of taken
off
how did Matt Damon die again with this
I'm right it's right here I don't know
this is like the others like I don't
realize that I'm dead like my life is
one long press junket and I just sit
here going like wow this is still
happening so I didn't go to heaven then
did Matt Damon survive on Mars you do
that with the help of Ridley Scott Mars
in our case was split between Budapest
and Wadi Rum and Jordan and I survived
with the help of a wonderful film crew
there you go
how did Matt Damon get Good Will Hunting
me he's got a minute yeah is Julianne
Moore ambidextrous misters yeah a little
bit that's a little ambitious left hand
but I bat and I cut and stuff like that
with my right so yeah is Julianne Moore
married mm-hmm is Julianne Moore related
to Mandy Moore is Julianne Moore Irish a
little bit a little bit Scottish but is
julianne moore related to Roger Moore
nope but you are related to Sean Connery
all right well those are your those are
your answers people she's ambidextrous I
didn't know and a Sagittarius and I
learned what her real hair color is hair
color that cutter head